I agree that there is a lot wrong with
Iran.
It's hostility to Israel.
It's appalling human rights record,
but I doubt that that record is worse
than that of Egypt or Saudi Arabia and
we don't hear much from the West about
that.
Thank you,
but there is another side to Iran.
The revolutionaries are growing older
and have a country to run.
It is a country with significant
elements of democracy.
It has a large Christian population and
also a significant Jewish population,
the largest but small Jewish population
in the Middle East,
outside Israel that even represented in
the Iranian parliament.
Iran has made overtures in the past
about improving relations with the West
in 2003.
It supported the American invasion of
Afghanistan at the same time.
It proposed normalizing relations with
us and he offered to rein back at
support for Hezbollah and Hamas and
there's Jack Straw said all it got was
to be called part of the access for
evil.
Iran unfortunately has many reasons to
be distrustful of the West,
the coup against Dr Moosa Deck simply
because he wanted to run soil for Iran
rather than for UK.
Are maintaining the shine power along
with the notorious,
most most sad supported secret police in
1983 of us shot down in Iranian civil
airliner killing 290 people and then
there was the help the west gave Sudan
was saying when he invaded in Iran,
it's impossible to understand the
security insecurity and the mentality of
Iran without understanding the Iran Iraq
war and the fact that they lost almost
as many people in that war as we lost in
the Second World War Iran.
Iran is not going to become the ally of
the West overnight,
if at all,
but there are common interests that we
have like fighting the Islamic state.
Iranians are not apocalyptic millenarian
madmen wanting to blow the world up.
I believe that this deal gives us the
best hope of improving relations with
Iran.
We have surely learned enough from our
disasters actions in the past to prefer
a negotiated settlement rather than to
push us yet again into another
catastrophic war in the Middle East.
Thank you.